Với cùng có hồi quay cùng sang cho 2 gàm người hiện tại vẫn chưa xong trước xin với liếm mồn
Tại vì tình có một cơ hồi quay cùng liếm châu có bạn này
Và không bao nhiêu hai mẹ tắng không bệnh
Lấy chính thức khai sạm lớp viên và đây là một lớp học lại từ đầu
Xương xin với liếm mồn sang cho 2 gàm người hiện nhau
Lớp học này sẽ tự yêu điện thêm một liếm hợp nữa
Để cho các bạn để hăng tự ngu học tập
Và bất yp liên cho bất yp của bạn, trong lớp viên của thầy
Lớp là các bạn, chứ được học và mười được sáng 28 của anh
Cùng gây khảo vệ tại là mười được sáng 24 của anh
Nếu mà khoảng này thì là một khoảng, là vẫn rất nguyên khoảng mồn
Lớp xin của mình là các bạn sạm dậy
Không tháng chỉ là viên một và viên thay gà
Nhưng mà có một cái dú cầu của rất nhiều bạn học xin
Bây giờ khoảng mồn là vào lớt thì mà phải xem này
Quả như vậy, thì thì thánh trực của bạn
Trinh tà mô tồn một mồn
Lấy dây là, từ đầu cho các bạn chút xin của liếm mồn
Các bạn hồi học, các bạn hồi xem này phải dạ
Các bạn hồi cống liếm, bây giờ cho tiết
Dạ, các bạn không còn mình xem này quá nhìn các bạn
Bởi vì các bạn không cố đơn trong quá xin
Chúng ta học tập truyền sình của liếm mồn
Vì đây là một số xin của cùng khó
Nếu như bây giờ, cơ hồi cố gồn này mà các bạn khoảng chưa xo ba sớm
Thì chất trắng vào năm, cơ hồi cơ kỳ hồi hợt
Bây giờ có mình đánh bây giờ, và trở bị lỗi
Trời là cũng sốc hay sạm cho khoảng viết bà này
Nếu như bạn mà mồn tăng gỳ lộ sình này
Được dạy lạc từ đầu, số xin của liếm mồn
Hãy nhắc tình trực tiếp với website, dưới hộn này
Bây giờ có liếm tăng gỳ lộ sình tiếp có tù này
Thầy lúc bất tù này, nhưng đừng giây lạc từ đầu vã nhá
Đăng gỳ gỳ gỳ gỳ hợp kếm nhạc tình như thế nhé